I put a gun on her and I say are you
[ __ ] married or not
a bad bad thing she [ __ ] a piano the
teacher
I'm a piano teacher I give one-on-one
lessons
and I have one student since the
beginning of the year
which I really like I flirt with her she
flirts with me oh boy and
um one student she's adopted with her
eyes oh there's really something going
on there and I want to make the next
move
but she's uh wearing a lot of rings
especially on on this fella how many one
one is what matters polygamist yeah but
she's flirting so much that it seems
like she wants more
so more I don't want to ruin any
marriage but I want to find out if she's
really married married or not
maybe she's a widow I don't know how I
mean this guy so I want to find out in a
conversation
um maybe you have some
um suggestions some tricks some moves I
could make moves how to find out in a
subtle way
my best move so far is
not very subtle it's very
confrontational asking here by the way
is this um engagement ring and if she
might say yes why
then I could say I only wanted to find
out how much flirting is appropriate
that's not that's my best move so far
maybe you have some ideas for me robot
it would be
very great
um yeah much much love from Germany hell
yeah thanks for doing this
um yeah goodbye doing I mean dude all
right
well that the whole thing we just uh
there's a lot of ways we could start
this one first things first you don't I
mean this guy dude I don't [ __ ] her yeah
I have had I no hello I have one student
since it's the beginning of the year you
would like to [ __ ] her that was a that
was the language of everything ruin my
business yeah
in Germany it is tradition to ruin your
whole business
he met one of his students okay not as a
language barrier thing so so is the word
confrontational it's the thing I do it's
very confrontational I say do you have a
husband or are you a veto
the husband died is so German dude I
mean how is she [ __ ] 65 dude I mean
like did your husband die dude okay this
I mean there is so much to [ __ ]
unpack I think first of all you can
believe what I'm curious about is if she
has a lot of rings on on that finger
it's Johnny Depp just ask why do you
have so many what's up with that one
finger you have so many rooms dude our
hands are just so heavy when she comes
in one hand's leading down because it's
the one finger yeah it's the wedding
finger he's talking about so go so he
said she has so many rings yeah so maybe
she's a [ __ ] Carney and she just like
has rings all over but he should say
take off your rings take off your rings
to play the piano it's easier take off
your engagement ring and if she says oh
it's not it's not an engagement ring and
he goes haha and then going for a kiss
that's a little tricky wrong all over
the piano it's a little tricky though
because I know you you don't want to be
like a sleaze roundabout just just ask
but in a plain way in a
non-confrontational way just be like I
noticed you have a lot of rings on that
one finger what what's that rank the
rank the Rings in order from one to nine
no but okay here's what I say don't [ __ ]
her okay obviously okay if you're if you
want to explore a love thing let's go
from this okay all you gotta do is say
I mean add it to the [ __ ] uh
lesson like if you're playing like
picture your husband you love him very
much right like this your husband what's
his name
she says either Greg then you know you
got a husband okay Greg you love Greg
and you're playing for Greg if she says
oh I don't have one then go like this I
oh really so that's very nice and then
play and then you know dude but how much
flirting is appropriate like you're
[ __ ] kind of flirtbot 2000 kind of
none though hello how are you
how much flirt before we commence lesson
I have noticed you have nine rings I
don't know which one is an engagement
ring however which how much flirtings
is appropriate
with the microphone still it doesn't
need it
yeah dude he has a microwave this was
the only one that you said turn it up
yeah true doesn't need it or needed it
more and held it too far everything on
that guy is beige dude his skin his lips
his nose his hair his eyes everything's
beige his shirt was beige he was a robot
he is a robot beige dude don't ever [ __ ]
your student yeah okay I have one
student I'm trying to ruin my business
I'd like to slide in and out of her but
yeah dude
[Laughter]
I don't know what move I should do but
the move I have is very confrontational
I put a gun on her and I say do are you
[ __ ] married or not
I say hands up student are you married
or not
she says yes I shoot her or teach songs
that are obvious about what if she is
engaged obvious what you want to do do
you know what I mean you could be like
we're going to learn this today
just two notes so so it's like so
obvious you're not even learning much
for the Wicked Game we play
when you're absolutely married but do
some shady things with your piano
teacher just put say play that
the teacher
she has so many rings
oh [ __ ]
answer this question even though I'm
singing are you engaged
it's not part of the song
[Laughter]
God damn oh my God is it a real
engagement so if the answer is yes how
serious is it would you explore
cramming so many words
would you explore during the horizontal
Mamba with your piano teacher
[Music]